after Latvia earlier this year lift when
you will be the next member to join the
euro club as from the first of January
2015 the General Affairs Council took
today the last necessary steps to allow
Lithuania to become the euro zone's 19th
member state giving in nearly six months
to prepare for the final change over
from liters to euros Lithuania has now
been invited to become member of the
single currency the euro club like other
euro enthusiasts I can say that it is my
pleasure and honor to receive this
historic message today that Lithuania
has passed this complex and rigorous
test of redness to introduce the euro
it's very solid the bath which has been
followed by byla terranea to join
because certainly Lithuania is not only
going to be a new member of the eurozone
but a very reliable member the council
also took note of the world program
proposed by the Italian presidency for
the next six months ministers discussed
also new ways to better monitor the
implementation of decisions taken by the
heads of state and government during
their meetings in Brussels as it works
now ministers prepare implementation
reports which are then presented to the
EU leaders but the idea is to make the
follow-up process more effective and
less bureaucratic finally ministers also
had a look at the work that needs to be
done until the end of the year to
prepare the review of the Europe 2020
growth strategy which sets ambitious
social and economic targets to be
achieved in the next five years